oui la question pour vous allez-y alors
d'abord je suis fâché contre vous parce
que j'ai regardé des années secretstory
ce n'est que très récemment que vous
avez avoué que les téléspectateurs était
dupe et non est-ce que j'ai jamais dit
si si si vous l'avez dit toute la vérité
vous avez problème je vous dire que
l'été puisque tous les secrets étaient
bino n'en ai voulu à samedi pourquoi
n'avez-vous pas dénoncer ça alors les
secrets n'étaient pas tous bidonné à
wayne y avait ce qu'on appelle un
casting et on avait un profil de
candidats à trouver
il y avait ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui
encore les bon perso mais bon personnage
qui n'avaient pas de secret donc
forcément quand un gars est très bien ou
une nana est très bien mais pas le trait
on lui en colle un kit un peu bidon ça
c'est vrai on avait dit qu'on appelait
les secrets mécanisée et pas de secret
bidon
certains étaient un peu farfelue mais
quoi non mais oh certes été un peu
parfois un peu farfelue mais c'était pas
inventé quant au fait que c'était
scénarisé ça n'était absolument pas
contrairement à ce qu'on a vu avec des
ouf
maintenant il n'y a pas de scénario le
défaut je trouve vers la fin de ces
quatre story c'est que la voix donné
trop présente et qui éventuellement
d'émission des actions
ouais quand vous lisez par ce père voit
la pression oui je me servais lequel
magali berda alors quel est le candidat
ou la candidate là comme ça que vous
vous voilà avec qui vous avez préféré
qui vous a marqué le plus dans toute
cette aventure et de tous les candidats
que vous avez pu entendre deux candidats
oui mais qui me fait le plus rire c'est
benoît dubois vraiment vraiment est il
vrai que les candidats étaient rémunérés
chaque semaine environ 500 euros
absolute à l'effet qu'un scandale la
télé réalité où on nous on va t'on
pouvait pas être candidat de jeu puisque
ils travaillaient en fait divers procès
qui avait un forfait de développement
qui fait peur de 100 euros par semaine
un peu plus
ou est-ce que tu as eu un crush pour une
candidate toute la vérité
non moi je dis rien j'ai mangé mes
baisers mais beaucoup iam en jeu de
zyriab non non non non non non non non
moi je voudrais savoir combien vous
demandiez pour votre saison de secret
story
[Applaudissements]
juste prix s'est amusé à internet c'est
plus qu'une fourchette 1 millions
d'euros
c'est dans cette ville
cet argent je vous donnerai le récif
dans pas longtemps utilisé bah je sais
pas j'attends que la pub à ribéry est il
vrai que les candidats été réveillée
dans la nuit pour aller au confessionnal
et comme il les appelait les yeux embués
il disait un peu des beti en femme pas
papa ma connaissance n'auront ce qui est
vrai c'est que à cause d or csa et du
fait qu'ils aient travaillé huit heures
par jour après le prime ont été limités
dans le temps et la voie pouvait plus
leur demander d'ordonner un ordre très
important c'était pas toi tu veux
professionnelle c est ce que tu
souhaiterais par hasard 38 cécile un
subtil mais c'était pour respecter la
loi et le code du travail c'est aux six
en un mot vous devais résumer toute
cette expérience temps sic resterez vous
dire les rythmes extraordinaire
[Applaudissements]
et répond quand je l'aurai décidé c'est
toi qu'on reparle en plus il oublie pas
il ya plus de questions secrètes une
dernière une audi rsq des grosses
bagarres parce que je croyais que tu
étais à coach à droite derrière les
portes il ya eu des bagarres à bien une
célèbre entre autres les fixes et leurs
dates un oui d'ailleurs et léo diffusé
par l'elysée on a diffusé au début et l
élan voyous trouver week-end dans la
maison alors je vous réponde sur le love
qu'ils allaient trouver un moyen très
intéressant il y avait une table de
salle à manger ils mettaient en fait une
serviette sur la table il se faisait une
calandre et mais il est dans et après on
avait créé la salle csa
voilà c'était plus la salle csa c'était
la salle bang bang voilà c'est tout les
candidats de télé réalité aujourd'hui
ils ont des joueurs offrent ils n'ont
pas le droit de travailler un jour et
sept jours sur sept et pas de 7 jours
sur 7 sur 7 optionnellement temps mais
pas sur la forme les raisons d'un espace
comme louis xi en toile et 7 jours sur 7